hello and welcome to 30 playing H escape
wow- to score against them and it's not
good let's see that we improve on that
if I am any moves g4 and both bishops
more both bishop moves are possible
let's c minus 2 and 3 not good okay an
interesting moment can I take on c6 this
is some sometimes interesting not sure
about here Bishop takes probably okay I
my dark squares I bit good to retail now
he wants to take on d5 and play
something with would be five that's a
bit loose we'll see
turn out too well probably this this
this whole combination of g4 and Bishop
d3 I wanted to try this normally I play
the bishop out to g5 first or Bishop d3
and keep the bishop on everyone and I
wanted to try this way of developing but
I didn't it didn't turn out well this is
comfortable for black now of course I
mean I'm not losing or saw anything like
that but it can definitely be happy I am
okay what am I doing here in the next
couple of moves probably care probably
canceling maybe I can't get in night a
true Queen moves to be six and before in
or something like that not very happy
with that but yeah whoops eh just a good
on wrong move and they have to get the
King out of them okay so night a to now
then before I am I need I need some kind
of lines open lines them
okay if he goes f5 in the next couple of
moves I i always have f3 I think it
should still be reasonably safe ok tries
to switch over all the way to h4
interesting well I can take on c5 and
take be 7 which is I mean greedier
absolutely very greedy and I have to
probably make some kind of prophylactic
move
you
teenage for this Knight f3 yeah so the
thing is i was just about i was thinking
maybe i can actually take i have got
root g for here and this is kind of
funny but maybe not a bad idea it's
actually interesting so I good night
Ruby for now tonight f6 though I wonder
if taking one c5 is an idea yeah why not
actually 493
it's got an idea for something like that
queen geforce also interesting
sounds interesting move look CF seven I
can take b7 this one okay night 9635
okay okay okay 526 it's no big deal
maybe bring that over here and I'd have
six maybe let's check okay
just getting nervous on the G file and
look G oneness definitely something that
it feels right here oh oh we're looking
simple tactics hi morning there was a it
was a tough position I mean very likely
it is good for white but simply
blundered that
now you can just take them take this
check the nonsense or cam white resigns
I had bad bad run I think this is a good
position for white but I simply miss
played it what does the engine give okay
about plus 1 10 point aid yeah it should
be good for white or a piece of those
sites just better but yeah i blundered
that I simply blundered their tactic and
tough it was a very tough position after
I added I don't did like my opposition
out of the opening but he I was
definitely okay again hmm hmm hmm
interesting question yet I should take
or not the engine also wants to take hey
this is this is kind of interesting not
sure if I need to do that or should do
that in the first place computer wants
to play Knight c3 and likes white yeah
probably right that night is that bishop
is also useful defender and it's not so
clear what this night is doing I mean
okay it is clear what is doing it looks
at the Foursquare but it's still
probably not a great idea yeah nice 9
p-5 was right directly attacking the
week pawn
my engine wants to pay property seven
years then that is necessary then why
this definitely in good shape now with
some advantage but okay yeah this I
simply overlooked a tech taken check now
and here yeah I'm completely completely
lost already yeah Queen g3 is still
hanging on even though it's
hi it's not so clear actually that's so
clear Knight f6 yeah kind of still
hanging on there yeah I don't know that
that opening result also i didn't like I
probably shouldn't play that early
Bishop d3 year they normally play Bishop
e3 and probably with some good reason
okay well thanks for watching